you realize it's kind of something that
should be uh nagging at you at this
point in that if you have if you happen
to own a lot of crypto assets all those
secret keys that control those crypto
assets are now sitting potentially
in your client you know in your on your
laptop if you want to
that sounds like a pretty bad idea
because if your laptop is compromised
all those secret keys can then be stolen
so it's kind of again important to
remember anyone who has your secret keys
can spend funds on your behalf and send
those funds wherever they want
and you might not ever ever be able to
recover those fans back yeah there have
been many reported cases of these things
happening so in fact keeping any these
keys in your browser is a pretty bad
idea because you might easily lose your
funds fortunately there are much better
options
so let's just walk through three
different options so one option is to
actually keep the funds at the exchange
yeah so
you don't control the secret keys in
your browser you just control them at
the exchange when you want to spend you
lock into the you log into the exchange
and you ask the exchange to transact on
your behalf there are also
custodial services uh popping up and if
you wanted to you can provide you can
give your keys to the custodial services
and their business is basically to keep
your keys
safe so that you can spend from them or
transfer assets to them
when you see fit in some sense custodial
services play the role of banks
now if you really want to hold the funds
yourself you really want to hold them
you know in your
in your hands you don't want to be the
mercy of any third-party service what
it's still a bad idea to keep them in
your in your browser instead what you
can do is you can buy what's called a
hardware wallet
and i just gave one example here of a
wallet called ledger so ledger is this
wallet over here basically it's a it's a
small usb device
that's going to protect your secret keys
and hardware so even if your laptop is
compromised they're not going to be able
to steal your secret keys in particular
when you want to spend from your from
your address what you would do is you
would plug the ledger device into your
laptop you would issue an instruction to
the wallet to go and spend and create
transactions
and spend those funds but now when the
wallet needs to sign the transaction
what the wallet would do is he would
talk to the ledger hardware device ask
the ledger device to sign the
transaction at that point the ledger
device is going to ask the user to
actually touch the device or confirm
that the transaction
this is really a transaction that the
user wants to make and once the user
confirms that the transaction is
legitimate that's when the ledger device
will sign the transaction give the
signature to the browser wallet and then
the browser wallet will propagate the
transaction to the rest of the network
so essentially even if your machine is
completely compromised there is no way
to spend funds on your behalf because
your laptop doesn't know what the keys
are it's only this ledger wallet that
knows what the keys are so that's the
second approach this is if you want to
really keep the keys in your hand
and the third approach which is kind of
a compromise here you can keep the keys
in your hands
but you also have a
co-signatory service like bitgo as an
example where what you do is you say
well you know in order to spend funds
from this address in fact two people
have to sign the transaction it's not
enough to just have one signature and in
this case what would happen is you would
sign a transaction yourself perhaps
using a ledger your ledger device but
that's not enough to spend the funds in
fact you would have to go to bitgo and
perhaps call them perhaps
connect with them
using a separate
password perhaps using uh your phone a
separate device you would have to tell
bit go yes i really do want to spend
those funds and once they
believe you basically that's when they
issue a signature
and so now you have two signatures that
authorize spending of funds so that uh
that's when the funds will actually get
uh transferred which means that even if
your entire um
uh
system and that's in your hand gets
compromised like somebody steals your
ledger device you know somebody breaks
into your laptop and so on they still
can't uh use your funds because they
also have to get the approval from bitco
the general advice is you know it's not
a good idea to keep them on your laptop
you got to do something more and we
listed a couple of options
uh uh right there so that's what i
wanted to say about managing uh crypto
currencies and crypto assets in the next
segment we're going to look at uh going
beyond the currency so what else can we
do with blockchains that has nothing to
do with currencies